bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france qu'est ce que vous retenez de
cette campagne électorale en allemagne
et bien les cartes sont complètement
rebattu souvenez vous avant les vacances
sont penser que finalement le chancelier
serait soit un futur chancelier verre ou
une fleur du chant sentent chancelière
ou alors armin laschet qui est le camp
des qui était le candidat désigné par
angela merkel est bien toutes les cartes
sont rebattues parce qu'il ya eu des
événements entre temps et cette montée
extraordinaire laquelle on 1 6 2 au love
shop le candidat du spd à deux raisons
principales deux événements
extraordinaires qui se sont passées et
qui ont rebattu les cartes il y a bien
sûr de les inondations catastrophiques
en rhénanie westphalie
je rappelle quand même que armin laschet
tu étais le ministre président de
rhénanie westphalie et il a été jugé
comme on est vraiment responsable des
retards notamment des retards des aides
qui est retardée z qui était promis aux
sinistrés de rhénanie westphalie et puis
il ya eu effectivement vous l'avez
montré à l'instant cette gaffe énorme
cerise ce rire massif en plein milieu
alors qu'il était avec le président
allemand en plein milieu des sinistrés
des inondations cela a eu un effet
ravageur donc c'est un véritable
effondrement lui a remis une hachette à
laquelle on a six et les cartes sont
rebattues parce que aujourd'hui on peut
considérer que olaf scholz et dans une
véritable dynamique d'ascension qui
pourrait bien sûr le lui permettre
finalement de gagner ces élections
législatives dans quelques semaines
c'est donc vraiment aujourd'hui quelque
chose qui rend très incertain le
résultat pour l'instant et le débat
télévisé de ce soir entre les trois
successeurs potentiels à un gala marqué
à d'autres va donc être déterminant
qu'est ce qui sera scruté de près ce
soir
ce qui va être très difficile dans ce
débat c'est que comme dans tout débat
télévisé il faut que chaque candidat
sache se démarquer par rapport aux
autres donc marque véritablement sa
différence donc c'est très important
qu'ils aient une certaine forme
d'agressivité par rapport à leurs
concurrents directs cela dit cela peut
leur poser un problème car il est
évident qu'à l'issue des élections
législatives allemandes
il n'y aura pas de majorité en allemagne
il faudra donc constituer une nouvelle
majorité donc une nouvelle coalition
donc finalement du débat est très
difficile pour les candidats et
notamment aussi bien pour le candidat du
spd que pour le candidat de la cd ou car
il va falloir à la fois marquer sa
différence et en même temps ménagé ses
adversaires pour éventuellement ouvrir
la voie à une possible grande coalition
qui de toute façon sera quasiment
obligatoire après des élections qui sont
très incertaines pour l'instant alors au
delà de cette nécessité de former une
coalition après les élections
législatives
qu'est ce qui attend le futur chancelier
ou la future chancelière allemande
voilà ce qui attend bien sûr c'est la
crise qui s'est développée avec le co
vide c'est le redressement s'est il faut
par exemple noté que aulas olaf scholz
le
candidat du spd avaient pris position
pour un emprunt européen donc c'est
quelqu'un qui était tout à fait dans la
dynamique d'une aide massive qui a déjà
développé pour sa propre région et je
crois que là c'est quelque chose
d'important c'est quelqu'un qui est
crédible d'autant plus que étant
ministre fédéral des finances il est
jugé comme quelqu'un de sérieux
quelqu'un de compétent et en plus
certains conservateurs considèrent qu'il
est dans la ligue est tout à fait dans
la lignée d'angela merkel c'est à dire
une certaine forme d'orthodoxie
budgétaire alliée à une forme au site de
certain dynamisme pour vous donner des
aides plus massive est plus importante
pour aider l'allemagne à sortir de ces
crises notamment de cette crise du coc
vide et donc là je crois que si on a
quelque chose qui est important à noter
on a un nouveau bolide à qui apparaît
sur la scène olaf scholz qui aujourd'hui
apparaît comme un challenger possible
pour la succession de le guen merkel
angela merkel qui a apporté son soutien
à ce candidat en difficulté de la cdo
est ce que ça peut changer la donne
ça peut changer la note dans la mesure
où effectivement le soutien qui avait
apporté un gala merkel armin laschet tu
est un soutien un petit peu difficile si
armin achète lui-même n'arrive pas à
honorer ce soutien il n'arrive pas à
remonter dans les sondages or
actuellement la la tendance qui se
dessine c'est plutôt un effondrement
cela pose aussi la question de la
crédibilité de celui qui a été soutenu
par angela merkel alors qu'une majorité
faible certes de la cd ou jugé que ce
candidat armin laschet tu étais un peu
trop juste pas assez compétent par
rapport à d'autres candidats qui étaient
jugés plus sérieux plus conservateurs
donc le fait d'avoir paradoxalement à
gauche un candidat plutôt conservateur
alors qu'elle droite le candidat a l'air
peut-être un peu plus fantaisistes cela
rabat bien sûr des cartes mais ça le ça
pose aussi un problème pour le candidat
du spd car le candidat du s p de nous
devra aussi convaincre son propre parti
qui lui est plus à gauche et qui était
assez exigeants en matière de réformes
sociales alors est-ce que ce candidat du
spd sera rassembler de manière assez
large à la fois son corps mais aussi une
grande partie de l'électorat allemand
c'est la grande question qui va se poser
dans les quatre semaines qui viennent
merci beaucoup pour votre un décryptage
françois paul et matiz journalistes
spécialistes à des institutions
européennes et c'est donc ce soir ce
premier grand débat télévisé entre les
trois successeurs potentiels à angela
merkel on suivra c'est évidemment avec
un attention